[Music]
[Applause]
i think they lost their stomach powers
[Music]
[Applause]
dog control reports ready sir
hell ready sir obviously departure
yard command signaling clear sir
maneuvering thrusters
new bring thrusters station
rescues that station keeping sir
[Music]
[Applause]
wax on wax off macdonald
wax on hat
wax off
concentrate look my eye
rocker hand thumb inside
wax on hat
axle
up done
up
down
up
down
other side look i always look eye
[Applause]
hold it huh
you guys are under arrest
[Music]
what are you night security
well no actually i'm a
pizza delivery
[Music]
stay down
did i mention i studied martial arts
[Music]
[Applause]
i've known all of you for so long
rose
lina
waverly
since we were babies and kids fighting
over dolls
it's amazing isn't it
[Music]
auntie lindo
auntie yinging
auntie on me
long time friends of my mother
you are like second mothers to me
in so many ways
truly
[Music]
i mean
you gave her back to me by finding my
sisters
you've given me something i can still do
for her
here i thought it was too late well it
isn't
[Music]
[Applause]
the price you pay
for bringing up either my chinese or
american heritage as a negative is
i collecting head
just like this
here
now if any of you sons have
got anything else to say now the [ __ ]
time
i didn't think so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
dance with me
[Music]
will
vivian shane
am asking you to dance with me
[Music]
i can't
there's no music
[Applause]
this is either a really smart move
or by far the stupidest thing that we've
ever tried well
we're about to find out
mush
i told you this was
[Music]
am i really high
or is this actually working oh
this is awesome
we're gonna be a white castle
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i forgot um
i've decided i won't let you kick me out
of the family since i'm a member of the
family who stand a reason that i would
get a vote and whether or not i get
kicked out and that vote would have to
be unanimous standard parliamentary
procedures so
all those in favor of not kicking camel
out of the family raise your hand
great motion to kick kamel out of the
family denied
so you guys can just talk to me
okay you're giving me the silent
treatment
i figured that was what was gonna happen
i have a solution so
hi how are you that's just a real basic
one you know
past the salt
practical
always with the comedy
mom
made that one specially for you
kamel
how did you become so much more handsome
than your brother
naveed [ __ ]
i admit this one is designed to stir up
some controversy
it's interesting how you can't really
kick someone out of your family because
they will always be
your family
i agree with that
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not leaving cause i'm scared
or because i think i'm not enough
because
maybe for the first time in my life
i know i am
i just love nick so much
i don't want him to lose his mom again
so
i just wanted you to know that one day
when he marries another lucky girl who
is enough
for you
and you're playing with your grandkids
while the town halls are blooming and
the birds are chirping
that it was because of me
a poor
raised by a single mother
low-class
immigrant
nobody
[Music]
[Applause]
do it
light them up
how long before the guns get back online
i have no idea
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
m
foreign
okay sir how do you say congratulations
dad goshi gong see ha ha
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you all get the best of me
you ain't seen the last of me
i may go but i'll come back around
[Music]
you can give me your best shot
give
[Music]
i'll show you
[Music]
[Music]
around
i'm here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how
i'm not pretty i'm good lucky
[Music]
[Applause]
and ever since i turned 13 i've been
doing my own thing making my own moves
24 7 365.
i wear what i want
say what i want and i will not hesitate
to do a spontaneous cartwheel if i feel
so moved
not to brag but being 13 means i'm
officially a grown-up at least according
to the toronto transit commission good
for you
[Music]
oh about the hustle am i right
[Music]
you